[Music]
he is the fashion world's reigning
superpower
whatever aspect of the business that
you're in in our industry
everybody looks at ralph lauren as the
model a dream maker who netted billions
by imagining what others wished for
every time i design clothes i'm making a
movie i don't think anybody since walt
disney
has been as successful in persuading
millions and millions of people to buy
into his fantasies
wherever you go ralph lauren's brands
project an aura of rarefied living
ralph's brand stands for classic
timeless
fashion the brand represents your
souvenir of this fabulous lifestyle that
you want to be a part of but his life
was not as picture perfect my sense was
he thought this would be the last time
he walked the wrong way
it wasn't not by a long shot we used to
joke that he always had the plan to take
over the world he's taken over the world
there's no doubt about it
ralph lauren is the most famous one-man
brand on the planet
a brand that is synonymous with a
superior lifestyle
ralph always knew that he wouldn't win
if he didn't take risks and he's always
pushing the envelope he keeps himself
awake at night he's worried that he's
going to fail he's obsessed
he's brilliant he's irratible he's
difficult and
he can also be kind and interesting and
sweet he's a
huge bundle of contradictions lauren
insists that the images he creates
communicate his story
and did not participate in the show
before he was ralph lauren
he was ralph lifshitz the youngest of
four children who wore his brother's
hand-me-downs
born in 1939 to jewish immigrant
working-class parents
he grew up in the bronx new york his
father was a house painter and amateur
artist
living with someone for whom aesthetics
mattered
would of course affect a child in that
household
michael gross is the author of genuine
authentic the real life
of ralph lauren he went to yeshiva and
he wore a yarmulke and he wore all the
other paraphernalia of orthodox jews
every single day he told me that at the
very beginning when he was living in the
bronx
he would go and escape to the movie
theater and literally
fall into the fantasies of the movies of
that era which
was really you know one of the great
moviegoing eras the late 40s and early
50s
warren helstein is one of lauren's
boyhood friends
we all as kids looked at the movie
screens and the
actors and how good they looked i know
ralph particularly liked
fred astaire and he truly did
project himself into the scenes in which
men like gary cooper
and gary grant were playing he sees the
characters that populate his dreams and
his
visions and that vision that
ability to step into a fantasy world
ralph brought to the fashion business in
one of his only two major television
interviews ever
lauren told charlie rose back in 1993
about the enduring impact of those
experiences
i was very influenced by movies i was
very influenced by
a world that had a sense of dream that
had a sense
of something else and what i was
influenced in these places was
the good guy the the the hopalong
cassidy
um not the corny guy but the
there was the man on the white horse my
sense was
i had an integrity inside me about what
i believed in
i i did it honestly and
but i had a point of view i was very
strong warren helstein says that when
they were teenagers
lauren asked helstein's father a tailor
to make him one of his first suits
but i remember going down to my father's
place with him and it was very difficult
you know just said my to my father's dad
do whatever he likes he says i can't
please him i said
okay that's that's it
even though he was a perfectionist
lauren was a guy's guy
he liked basketball best i would say
okay we're all good
how are you in 2011 when oprah winfrey
came to interview him on his colorado
ranch
lauren shared his earliest ambitions did
you always want to be a cowboy
i want to be baseball play i want to be
basketball player i wanted to be an
actor i want to be a dancer
actually i wanted to be batman if you
don't that's the secret i'm telling you
and everyone out there
when he was in his late teens he and his
brother jerry
opted for a name change as ralph said to
me the problem with the name lipschitz
is it had the word
in it and he endured endless teasing
that continued through school i'm sure
into the army
i believe that ralph suggested to me
that the name lauren came from lauren
bacall
who you know was a great style icon
as well as a great actress following
high school
lauren worked as a salesman while taking
business classes at night
he never got a degree in 1964
after a short stint in the army 26 year
old lauren married
ricky lowbeer a receptionist he met at a
doctor's office
he married the girl who would look
perfect in the convertible with her
blonde hair flowing
ricky became his model his his backstop
ricky was always i think in the back of
his mind
[Music]
still looking for his place in the world
lauren set his sights on new york's
fashion industry
he became a salesman for brooks brothers
and then a series of necktie
manufacturers
i took him to his first polo match at
blindbrook
where we were exposed to fabulous things
the silver the leather the horses the
tall
slinky blondes big hats and
just a high society that we really
weren't
uh knowledgeable of but certainly
it didn't take us a moment to appreciate
it that fabulous world
transformed lauren's vision he called me
up and said he was going to open up his
own business
and what was my opinion about the name
and he said he had it down to
players or polo and i said ralph
polo is totally elitist hardly anybody
knows anything about it
but everybody plays something so there's
no choice it's got to be players
he said okay thanks a lot goodbye
and then the rest is history
it was the era of plain narrow ties when
lauren offered up a radical design
concept colorful wide ties
striking out on his own one of his first
stops bloomingdale's
marvin traub was the former ceo and
president of bloomingdale's
shortly before he died he spoke about
the brash young designer
he showed them to the bloomingdale tie
buyer
who said i like them i'll buy them but i
don't want that ralph lauren label on it
i want a bloomingdale label
now here's ralph starting and struggling
in business
about to get an order from
bloomingdale's he closed the sample case
and said i will not accept the order
without my name
[Music]
several months after ralph lauren walked
away from an offer at bloomingdale's
the renowned store called him back i
thought the ties were terrific
and if he wanted his name on it that was
fine because i felt the ties would sell
and they did other well-known names in
men's clothing also wanted in
including paul stewart and neiman marcus
within a year lauren sold a whopping
half million dollars of ties
the designer had designs on something
even bigger
to expand his brand he aimed to do so he
told charlie rose
by envisioning clothing that he himself
would want to wear
what you thought you can buy in england
what you thought cary grant was wearing
in fred astaire
you could not walk into a store and buy
when i came along
the business was not at all like the
things that i made you could not buy
you couldn't find it bloomingdale's saw
potential
and profit in lauren's line we worked
closely
from the ties to men's shirts to
suits sport coats slacks the total men's
collection
and then he came and said marvin i'd
like to do a women's business
i think the most important break for
ralph lauren was probably getting a
boutique of his own in bloomingdale's
it was the moment when someone outside
of ralph's fantasy existence
agreed with him and brought him into the
world of commerce
this was the first time that
bloomingdale's had given a designer his
own
in-store boutique and the business grew
very rapidly
ralph as in everything else knew exactly
what he wanted
in the shop what he wanted on the floors
what he wanted on the walls
it created really a ralph lauren
environment
and it's all ralph's dream menswear
designer john varvatos was a protege of
lauren's
if you go back into the 60s and 70s
people put things on a mannequin they
never told stories
ralph took you into a fantasy world
ralph took you to an island he took you
to the hamptons
he took you to the west three years
after his first ties went on sale
lauren won the oscar of the fashion
industry the 1970 cody award
for his menswear line and in 1971
lauren bought the first of what would be
many luxury cars
pulitzer prize architecture and design
critic paul goldberger
has reported on ralph lauren's famous
car collection
i think it was a mercedes convertible
that he couldn't quite afford
at that point he bought anyway because
he
understands that very kind of
aspirational reach that he's trying to
sell to other people
he reached back to his earlier fantasy
that polo match
and introduced his signature emblem the
polo player
but despite strong sales the company
found itself in financial trouble
to keep it going lauren was forced to
invest most of his personal savings
one hundred thousand dollars he also
hired a new business partner
retail executive peter strom who pitched
in
and bought ten percent of the business
for six thousand dollars
i think he was very worried they were
delivering everything late
their distribution pattern was all wrong
we solved those problems and we got the
right
stores to buy the right amount of things
to display
everything properly two years after
strom's arrival
and back on track lauren's brand got a
boost
when his men's clothes were cast in the
great gatsby
his ability to create clothes that
looked like costumes that looked like
clothes that looked like costumes
was unequaled in american fashion hi
hi but i actually think that the claim
that he designed annie hall was
more important the annie hall look would
inspire one of lauren's earliest women's
collections
and the designer himself was often the
featured model in his brand's ad
campaigns
commercial director jeff madoff has shot
many of ralph lauren's fashion shows
he wears this stuff so he's become the
embodiment of what he creates
like frank perdue with his chickens you
know ralph in his clothes there was an
authenticity to it
the company launched a blitz of new
collections
including a wide-ranging home collection
lauren
also licensed his name to other products
trading a measure of control
for capital now flush with cash
in 1986 ralph lauren went all
in spending 30 million dollars to open a
stand-alone flagship store
housed in new york city's historic
rhinelander mansion
my wife and i were there opening day at
two o'clock in the afternoon
and i said the store was packed with
people i said ralph how are you doing he
said i think i'm doing all right
and i said ralph you're a retailer you
can ring off the cash register now
and the manager came back and said
we have 41 000 in and ralph said is that
good
and i said that's very good then i went
back to my office and the phone rings
about 5
30 and it's ralph marvin we have a
hundred and one thousand dollars
and how is that and i said it was
terrific
this was ralph learning to be a retailer
i think it told his story to the world
anybody who came to new york it's like
on the tour guide of new york you know
you understand ralph lauren's message
very clearly when you go through there
when you walk by those windows you get
it
as the business continued to grow lauren
pushed his employees
harder than ever there's a vast team of
designers and creative executives
they do the designing they do just about
everything but they
bring it to ralph and finally it's ralph
who decides and there are actually
this amazing thing little tiny stickers
that get put up on idea boards and they
say
rl likes and in
that act ralph lauren takes possession
of those
clothes of those designs and deserves
the credit
ralph pays more attention to detail than
anybody i've ever met in my
life and when he is designing
and he's looking at the clothes he'll
look
and want a lapel ever so much
more peaked or ever so much narrower or
he likes to plan that he wants it to be
bigger
in 1986 the estimated worth of the
privately held company
was 600 million dollars and lauren not
his models
was the cover shot it would seem that
life couldn't get any better for lauren
when he launched his next women's
collection
but behind the scenes something very
alarming was shaking up the fame
designer
we were top of the st regis hotel and
the finale of the show ralph came out
and i saw his face unlike i had seen it
before
and i saw he was fighting back tears i
started crying
there was something going on i didn't
even know what it was it was just
visceral
no one but those closest to him knew
that lauren had been diagnosed with a
brain tumor
it was one of those things that you just
didn't want to believe
couldn't happen to ralph what did it
mean for the future there was all those
questions at the time
[Music]
as i was riding home in the taxi and i
heard on the news reports that designer
ralph lauren
was being admitted for emergency brain
surgery wow
oh yeah my god
sure i worried i felt so bad for him
you know fortunately
the tumor was benign after surgery there
was a long road ahead
and new priorities oh i don't think he
worried
about what would happen to the business
i think he worried about living
about his life lawrence shared his
ordeal with charlie rose
i remember when i came home from the
hospital
and um i took a walk in central park
and i was very weak and i saw some guys
running in the park
running and sweating i said to myself i
want to do that
several weeks later lauren returned to
work i think he came back even more
aggressive than ever but
i think he was a little bit more relaxed
a little bit more laid back and maybe
was valuing every moment a little bit
more
he launched a fitness wear collection
and created a top-selling perfume
he spent millions promoting these lines
and the product universe surrounding
them
james fallon editor of women's wear
daily calls ralph lauren a powerhouse in
the magazine world
because he's one of the biggest
advertisers out there if i launch my
fragrance and i take an ad out and or
series of ads you're going to then
do a profile of me i mean look at the
number of magazines
that did put him on the cover when he
had his
40th anniversary and that reflects the
extent to which they appreciated his
financial support in past years
appreciated and also depended on it
a 200 million dollar annual advertising
budget
is an 800 pound gorilla ralph lauren
sits wherever he wants and if that's the
cover of your magazine
ralph's going to be there lauren's
dominance was also evident
when audrey hepburn presented him with
the council of american fashion
designers lifetime achievement award
there was one of his muses his icons
audrey hepburn the woman that he watched
when he was a little kid in the movies
now handing him this statue that for him
could have been the oscar
remember the princess i got her
with the launch of lauren's upscale
purple label in 1994
the company looked great to the
untrained eye after all
sales were at an all-time high but that
only told half the story
heatha prabhakar is a retail business
journalist
like every retailer that has big dreams
it just grew too quickly there was a lot
of capital
expended in order to make that brand
where he wanted to be
that combined with a very lackluster
operations in terms of distribution
created
really a perfect storm for a company
that was almost on the brink of
bankruptcy
lauren needed a lifeline and found it
with goldman sachs
the investment firm purchased 28 percent
of polo ralph lauren
for 135 million dollars that was
surprising to us because we never
realized that he had
been that close to the you know back to
the wall financially
and i think that's sort of what led to
the goldman sachs investment
they're very good about identifying
where the growth is and what's going to
be a company
that's going to have long-term growth
and that's exactly what they saw in
ralph lauren
and the infusion of cash meant
exponential growth
with polo ralph lauren opening new
stores and overhauling older ones
by 1997 ralph lauren was the top selling
designer in the world
consumers spent almost five billion
dollars a year
on his products goldman sachs saw
greater potential
and pressed lauren to go public he
wasn't so sure
he always had concerns that once it was
a public company
he would have less freedom of action
that it was no longer
his own brand because he had
shareholders and a board to deal with
[Music]
despite his initial reservations ralph
lauren decided to take his company
public in june
nineteen ninety seven liz dunn a retail
analyst at mcquarrie capital
has been tracking lauren's company for
years part of the
challenge with going public is that
investors
want to see growth quarter to quarter
um year to year in a very consistent
linear fashion
and so i think in the early days of the
company's history as a public company
they sort of struggled with that
when he first went public we would cover
his annual meetings and he would stand
in front of a shareholders going wall
street doesn't understand me our shares
are
just sitting there they don't really
move i wish they would get what we do
lauren was now working to satisfy his
shareholders
the company began to sell in more stores
but sales growth slowed
and profit margins declined and 16
months after its opening day high of 33
dollars a share
it fell below 17 i know that it
tormented him we talked about it
he talked about it he was frustrated
that wall street couldn't see
what was abundantly clear to him and
always had been since 1967
that he was it but he was the guy it
drove him crazy
um and it was into that environment that
came
a man named roger farah who was one of
the great retail executives in america
roger farah came over and really
restructured the unsexy parts of the
business
supply chain operations one thing he
also did
too was that he bought back those
licenses he brought those brands
back in house and made sure that all
those brands were underneath the ralph
lauren umbrella
they're going through a tremendous
growth period and
i had suggested that we put together
something that really codify the
polo brand message and we called it
ralph lauren
philosophy it's a brand video that
lauren commissioned
the way i do collections what inspires
me is a story or a theme that gets to me
that says i know how to build this
i don't build a collection from a sleeve
or from a specific fabric i build it out
of a dream
control to him is very important and
this was a way to present a unified
message
where he didn't have to be there but it
was like he was there
lauren continued to expand with an eye
on international sales
he opened flagship stores in milan tokyo
and even moscow america is represented
in
france by mcdonald's and ralph lauren
i mean you know which one makes our
culture look better in paris
i think the ralph lauren store it's
really become a kind of
symbolic american embassy but in the
summer of 2012
the all-american designer was attacked
when news reports revealed that the team
usa uniforms lauren designed
were not made in the usa made in china
this is china
china i think they should take all the
uniforms put them in a big pile and burn
them
the company said the uniforms for the
2014 winter games would be produced in
the united states
throughout his career ralph lauren has
carefully cultivated his own image
he has homes on fifth avenue in jamaica
long island
and bedford new york as well as a
seventeen thousand acre ranch in
colorado
where he spends time with his wife and
three grown children
he also spends time and lots of money on
his pet
passion cars are fun and toys and they
all
offer you a different experience to me
they work so hard this 2010 promotional
video
announces a paris exhibit of some of
lauren's 60-plus vintage cars
he once told me his car collection is
something he does
first because he just loves cars and
responds to them and he doesn't collect
art
uh unlike most people in his income
bracket he said you know you can't drive
a painting and he loves the idea of
being able to take
any of his cars and drive it around on a
sunday afternoon say
paul goldberger says that lauren has
changed some of the car's
original colors he sort of looks at
something
and says this is wonderful
and exciting and beautiful but it
actually could be even
better and i want to make it even more
perfect for 40 years ralph lauren's
pursuit of perfection
has kept him firmly in charge as ceo and
chairman of the board of the company
that wears his name
i think that that you know small symbol
of the polo pony is is enduring and it's
something that customers over a long
period of time have chosen
this is probably the best long-term
story
in my coverage because there are these
variety of growth opportunities that are
really driving
a doubling or more of sales over the
next several years
the former thai salesman at age 72
is one of the world's wealthiest people
worth seven and a half
billion dollars i think that the last
piece of ralph lipschitz
that remains in ralph lauren is
a kernel of insecurity and it is the
fuel that
runs the engine that runs the person who
personifies the brand
ralph doesn't sit on his laurels for one
minute not for one minute
i mean you can enjoy the moment but you
have to understand that you have to keep
things going and you can't be a
one-trick pony
speaking of ponies
[Music]
[Music]
you